[Music]  this is the trio of our dreams as a  surprise a double dose of Paris Jackson  and Hilton Plus Hilton sister Nikki  stole the show at the Casa of Los  Angeles evening to foster dreams gala  Wednesday night the ladies dressed to  impress in gorgeous gowns for the annual  charity event honoring Paris and Nikki's  mother Kathy Hilton Paris and Paris  presented together on stage taking turns  gushing over Kathy then Paris squared  hit up the after-party  check out the king of pops daughter  kicking off her heels and cuddling up to  the 37 year old heiress of course they  go way back  I've known her since she was born my mom  and Michael grew up together since  they're teenagers and we're best friends  but she's so beautiful and so sweet and  such an amazing soul I loved her so much  like a sister  Paris Hilton took to Instagram with a  selfie of her crew captioned love my  sisters  [Music]  [Applause]